you put out a list of the dumbest
mistakes that guys make on the first
three dates and I want to go through
these the first one was they're way too
shy and stick to surface level talk so
many guys are trying to give the woman a
fun experience and that's not what women
who are looking for commitment are
looking for they're tired of the fun
they want substance tell her stories
that illuminate what your life goals are
that illuminate what your values and
principles are don't tell her life
stories that try to make her impressed
by who you are or make her feel sorry
for you that is what attracts women but
surely you also need to come across as
being fun you can't just do the most
boring thing in the world so how do you
balance these two if you are talking
about what is most deeply passionate to
you how could it possibly not be fun yes
if you're just rambling on for six hours
about your stock portfolio but if you're
having an intimate conversation with
another human being explaining that and
then learning her Mission learning her
desires what she's passionate about it
is fun for a purpose that drives
education about the other person